[Musique]
je revois mon arrière grand père
[Applaudissements]
moi je ne suis pas
c'est vous c'est vous qui chantez la non
mais c'est moi qui chante les maisons
parce que je viens de vous reconnaitre
sur la pochette je sais moi mais c'est
absolument mais vous êtes en même temps
marché aux puces est prise si vous êtes
chanteur je suis discret chanter en même
temps et c'est facilement compatibles
moi je pense oui je crois comment est-ce
que ça vous est venue la chanson savais
en venant lui dise que ça me donne envie
de changer voilà oui c'est tout ah oui
en seulement 6 pour que compliqué que ça
et retrouver votre inspiration ici aux
professionnels reconnaissent
l'aspiration de ma première chanson
auprès de magie c'est
ma femme qui a des idées heureuses c'est
pourquoi les rimbaud deux jeunes quant
au marché du kremlin bicêtre
on a tout ce qu'on veut sans casser la
tête le clair de lune et le soleil et
des tas de choses sans leur pareil c'est
pourquoi chaque dimanche matin elle voue
une au marché du kremlin
mais c'est complet
là ce n'est pas un pas mais
[Applaudissements]
bachy
seul
du
michel
[Applaudissements]
et
du marché
[Applaudissements]
du
abi saab
achats
attend le bus
attendre
est sympathique et
oui bon
du marché
[Musique]
ça donne une vraie nuit
elle part c'est dimanche et jolie dans
ce marché en pleine forme attends
domaine la richesse romani elle y
entraînent leurs marmots et même ses
copines de boulot sa cousine l'antre de
saint malo là quand charlotte des songes
arnaud et tous ball
jean pellet
ça sonnait vraiment je vois même
au marché européen
ça
du kremlin
j'ai
ils ont
sourire aux leurs
cuba
selon une chaîne
du marché
ce
du père
m
elle m'a fort si ça
il ya un an et je paye c'est trop dit
au
marché
heroku
seul du
habitat
et je revends tous qu'elle
ce que
c'est la semaine
au marché
je
du
c'est
il a
archer
ce
ça
quand même là
[Musique]